good morning john yesterday i was part
of the unveiling ceremony of the 75th
annual doomsday clock this is basically
a subjective measure of how close to
doom we are super fun you've probably
noticed that there's been a lot of bad
piling up over the last three years
pandemics and climate change and rising
isolationism and fascism feels
reflecting that the clock has been set
at 100 seconds to midnight for the last
three years which is as close to
midnight as it has ever been in those 75
years as the kids say big yike
i is it the kids that say that when they
asked me if i would be interested in
giving some remarks i was like only if i
can be hopeful about it and they're like
of course that's yes yes we want that
then i looked at a couple of the
previous years and some of what was
being said about this year i was like
honestly this seems quite bad so then i
sat down to what was a challenging
writing assignment i was going to be
going last after a bunch of people sort
of like went over why things are
particularly bad right now and in many
ways worse than they have been for a
long time and then say something hopeful
and like ideally empower it and i want
to talk about how i took that challenge
on uh just as sort of a writing
assignment i started out by saying that
just because you might be staying in the
same place doesn't mean you're not
active it doesn't mean you're staggered
which means that we can talk both about
the good news and the bad news and there
is plenty of both so that was my
transition out of what i knew would be
sort of bad news coming from the person
before me
then i zoom way out we think far more
about what happened this morning than we
do about what happened four billion
years ago even though that thing that
happened four billion years ago
is a bigger deal and a bunch of water
and energy and carbon was like hey i'm
gonna be a lie and then depending on how
you count and also reality that we
haven't uncovered yet somewhere between
a few million and a few hundred thousand
years ago
the universe started to talk to itself
about itself it started to be like wow
that's pretty and that's us like that's
this like this is the universe talking
to itself
yeah so let's keep an eye on that
because there's a reason why we're so
worried it's because this is really
wonderful so we're protecting something
great so that's good a little bit of
perspective you don't usually hear when
you're talking about multilateral arms
treaties but my most important trick
here and something that i think we would
all benefit a great deal from is talking
about the fact that things are hard
for reasons like you right now are in
the middle of the largest communications
revolution in the history of the human
race
so like yeah we're gonna be bad at it
doesn't mean we should resign ourselves
to being bad at it doesn't mean we can't
be better but like it's not surprising
that we're having a hard time i'm
getting legitimately worried by the
number of people who seem to think we
could solve these problems if only
humans weren't so awful and stupid and
bad i think that idea is seductive i
think that it is tremendously
disempowering and i think that it is
objectively wrong humans do things that
were once impossible constantly like the
this that we're doing right now was once
impossible and in the future we will do
many things that are currently
impossible i think that getting stuck in
disempowerment is the worst place to be
for challenging institutions and solving
hard problems rage without an outlet is
only ever going to make things worse so
my remarks i decided to offer an
alternative to this once in a while
instead of getting mad get curious start
with a person or an institution that
deeply discusses a big problem that
might be the prison policy initiative
for incarceration david roberts's volts
newsletter and podcast for climate
change or fair fight and stacey abrams
for voting rights spend some time
engaging with those problems on a deeper
and deeper and deeper level and even
listen to people who disagree with you
about those things so you can understand
not the most awful radical terrible
version of those arguments but the
arguments that they're making that are
actually convincing people you will
realize that these big heart problems
are made up of thousands of smaller
problems and that each one of those
smaller problems has a bunch of people
working on them and if each of us is
focused on one of those problems we're
going to be way more effective than if
all of us are focused on all of them and
thus not engaging deeply on any of them
and that is how i hope i wrote a talk
about doomsday that wasn't depressing
jon you can see those remarks at a link
in the description i will see you on
tuesday